there are a whole bunch of Trumpets and
even some non Trump Republicans who are
getting hugely bamboozled about the job
market and as a result the state of the
economy so let's first talk about if you
want to analyze how an economy is doing
I've always said you can't look at one
thing the stock market is a popular
thing to look at if the stock markets up
we've got a good economy if it's down
we've got a bad economy but it's only
one piece it only affects on average the
wealthier who disproportionately own
shares of stock so by itself it doesn't
tell us how the economy is doing at all
the unemployment rate is another piece
but the one that's widely published
which is called the u3 you don't have to
understand too much about this but when
we hear about all unemployment is 3.7
percent that's what's called the u3 it
falls very short of telling us
everything that we need to know
inflation and the Consumer Price Index
is another element of how an economy is
doing the strength of the dollar effects
other aspects of our economy the quality
of the jobs that people have wage growth
versus wage contraction or wage
stagnation and very often this becomes
completely politicized and in the end
any casual observer of politics and
economics loses what it actually is that
is taking place you have Republicans
saying Republican presidents have great
job markets and economies Democratic
presidents have bad ones the opposite
true for Democrats and what I've been
trying to do is to get past that so for
example I told you during the 2012
presidential campaign whether Obama wins
re-election or whether Mitt Romney wins
the economy will likely be pretty good
the next four years
Republican labor force conspiracy
theories were wrong under Barack Obama
but their labor force bragging under
Trump is also wrong it's wrong on both
sides of the equation as the case may be
so the point today is that one big piece
that's missing from the great job market
that Donald Trump claims is the quality
of jobs there is now a metric for this
which is the Cornell CPA
US private sector job quality index and
the name isn't so much important but
what it does is it looks at the ratio of
high wage high hours jobs to low wage
low hours jobs there's two ways that a
job could be a low quality job it could
be a low wage job or it could be a low
hours job this index has steadily fallen
since 1990 for the last thirty years
part of this is because of the
replacement of lots of jobs that have
been lost making things with service
jobs that includes restaurants and many
others a whole bunch of the recent job
gains not just under the trump
administration but under obama as well
have been in retail leisure hospitality
that includes restaurants and other
parts of industry waste management is
another area the sector's that have been
growing pay a far lower weekly income
than this job the manufacturing jobs and
other jobs that have been going away
either because they've been eliminated
or moved overseas so the top-line u3
rate that unemployment rate that's often
publicized the one Trump brags about
that's under 4% is low Donald Trump of
course when it was low under Obama said
the numbers were phony now he brags
about those numbers as evidence of a
great job market but the more important
thing is that the quality of the jobs
keeps getting worse and because the
income levels of the high quality jobs
keep going up while low quality jobs
don't this is furthering inequality the
gap is growing even more in the United
States now it's important to also note
very often the argument is made that
when you have a low u3 unemployment rate
you have a lot of people working two
jobs and that's a sign that that
actually the economy is weak this is
very often a red herring and it's a red
herring here if you actually look at the
number of people working two jobs right
now it's quite low historically so I
don't you know I I know that that's a
talking point I could use if I merely
wanted to play partisan politics that's
not what I'm here to do I'm actually to
tell you the what the truth is in the
real world
the right loves using that talking point
let's not use it okay we don't need to
this is where we come back to our
strategy from the left from the side
that wants the socially democratic
reforms we can't pretend that a pretty
good economy isn't pretty good by the
standards that are used to measure
economies the economy is pretty good
right now a lot of it has nothing to do
with Donald Trump whatsoever but let's
focus on the things that aren't going
well people are working jobs that they
hate to keep health care that's terrible
okay wage stagnation really bad
inequality terrible and furthered by
what we're talking about here the
replacement of quality jobs with
low-quality jobs lack of democratic
workplaces we've talked about the
democratization of the workplace that's
a problem stock market to the extent
that it benefits some people it's riding
high it's not going to last forever it
never does we lose credibility when we
attack them in the factually
indefensible ways that they attack us
but we don't need to do that because
there is plenty of bad to go around and
that's where we should be focusing our
energies and to be to be perfectly frank
it favors the policies we're advocating
for separating health care from
employment democratizing the workplace
dealing with inequality whether it's
with a higher progressive marginal tax
rate taxing capital gains at ordinary
income we have all the different tools
in our disposal all of the problems that
are really the problems now point to the
reforms we want to make so let's not
maybe miss the forest for the trees is
not the the right metaphor here but
let's not do what they do when we don't
need to do it from a moral perspective
let's not stoop to their level but it
also doesn't benefit us because focusing
on the real problems points to the
solutions being the suggestions we've
been making Social Democrats have been
making for a very long time do you feel
like you just don't have enough time to
become as intellectually well-rounded as
you would like to be that they're just
not enough hours in your week for you
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work I've
just finished listening to upheaval by
Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a tremendous
author whose work I've previously
recommended excellent book looking at
some of modern history's biggest
national crises to figure out how
different countries ended up in such
precarious situations Blinky's has
totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for blinka stay
of books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video